[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue en direct sur
public sénat édition spéciale de
présidentielle à 360 voici les titres
première cérémonie officielle pour
emmanuel macron mois après sa victoire à
la présidentielle
ils étaient ce matin aux côtés de
françois hollande pour les
commémorations du 8 mai la passation de
pouvoir entre les deux hommes aura lieu
dimanche prochain à l'elysée
à 39 ans il devient le plus jeune
président de la république avec 66,1 %
des voix devant marine le pen qui
obtient 33 9% des suffrages
nous reviendrons sur cette ascension
éclair mais aussi sur les défis qui
l'attendent alors que 16 millions
d'électeurs que se sont pas exprimés
dans les urnes
la bataille des législatives a débuté
emmanuel macron vaut construire une
majorité de changement pour cela en
marche et rebaptisé la république en
marche
mais l'étroitesse du socle électoral
risque de compliquer la tâche le front
national et l'eire et la france
insoumise se disputent le titre de
première force d'opposition analyses et
débats dans un instant et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez réagir sur
twitter à cette émission en direct le
hashtag présidentielle à 360 pour
m'accompagner ce soir saveria roseq en
direct de l'elysée nous écouteront
également richard ferrand qui s'exprime
depuis le qg dans marche je vous disais
en titre la victoire est nette pour
emmanuel macron avec à 66,1 % des voix
il devance clairement au marine le pen
la candidate au fn qui obtient 33 points
9 % mais le taux élevé d'abstention
liste et de blancs et nuls fragilise la
victoire d'emmanuel macron ce matin cet
emprunt de gravité
conscient des responsabilités qui
découlent de son élection qu'il s'est
rendu aux commémorations du 8 mai 45
aux côtés de françois hollande tout un
symbole quand un calme et c'est la
première image des deux présidents
ensemble
à l'occasion des commémorations du 8-mai
emmanuel macron place c'est pas dans
ceux de françois hollande élu hier soir
le nouveau président de la république ne
sera investi que dimanche mais déjà
l'actuel chef de l'état a invité son
successeur à cette cérémonie officielle
le président hollande qui à plusieurs
reprises guide ostensiblement son
successeur pour lui indiquer la marche à
suivre et afficher leur complicité
françois hollande qui aujourd'hui ne
cachait pas son émotion et beaucoup
d'émotion d'être sur ces lieux et puis
je vais beaucoup d'émotion aussi disons
le très franchement très sincèrement de
donner un à emmanuel macron la marche à
suivre
une première image ensemble symbolique
avant la passation de pouvoir est une
introduction au protocole emmanuel
macron qui a aujourd'hui rencontré pour
la première fois en tant que président
de la république les principaux
responsables des forces armées
une cérémonie où étaient présents de
nombreux politiques dont nicolas sarkozy
de son côté françois hollande vit
désormais ces derniers jours en tant que
président de la république en exercice
[Musique]
deux présidents qui seront à nouveau
réunis dans les jardins du sénat
mercredi pour les cérémonies commémorant
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
[Musique]
et justement cette cérémonie de
l'esclavagé en direct du palais du
luxembourg sera à suivre mercredi sur
notre antenne dès 11 heures et hier
plusieurs milliers de personnes étaient
rassemblées sur l'esplanade du louvre
pour célébrer la victoire d'emmanuel
macron dans une ambiance de boîte de
nuit à leur retour sur cette soirée avec
sandra cerqueira
[Musique]
une explosion de joie à l'annoncé des
résultats et surtout un grand
soulagement pour les soutiens des
manuels macron l'objectif était de ne
pas être sous la barre des 60%
honnêtement c'est par contre un pour
cent que malgré tout c'est plus qu'on
nous avait annoncé depuis un petit bout
de temps donc ça soulage c'est un
nouveau départ pour la france pour
l'europe et c'est pourquoi ils sont des
milliers sur l'esplanade du louvre a
savouré cette victoire paraît sont
inimaginables il ya quelques mois encore
par les soutiens de la première un
président aussi jeune il s'est révélé
sur le devant de la scène aussi
rapidement au terme d'une campagne qui
est parti de rien en à peine un an
c'est juste incroyable la fête prend des
allures de boîte de nuit puis l'ambiance
se fait plus solennel 22h30 le nouveau
président arrive seul au son de l'aude à
la joie
[Musique]
la mise en scène se veut à la hauteur du
défi
[Applaudissements]
je suis ce soir avoir un mot pour les
français qui ont voté pour moi sans
avoir nos idées vous vous êtes engagé et
je sais qu'il ne s'agit pas là d'un
blanc seing
la prochaine étape les élections
législatives qui inquiète de nombreux
militants h quand ça veut dire qu'on se
mette au site de va dire que c'est
indicative avec un parti qui a pas
vraiment de consistance actuellement
c'est un mouvement comme c'est sûr
qu'ils aient à se penser à rebattre les
cartes convaincre à droite comme à
gauche et surtout construire une
majorité parlementaire incontournable
pour mettre en oeuvre son projet
et malgré son score élevé emmanuel
macron c'est que son élection ne vaut
pas blanc seing 16 millions d'électeurs
ont refusé de choisir entre lui et
marine le pen
un rejet dont le nouveau président devra
tenir compte julie hulin la france vient
d'élire le plus jeune président de son
histoire
emmanuel macron remporté l'élection avec
un peu plus de 66% des voix un résultat
supérieur à celui envisagé par les
sondages à l'issue du premier tour 20,7
millions d'électeurs ont choisi le
candidat dans marche soit près de deux
fois plus que marine le pen
une victoire nette mais à relativiser
car l'autre record historique c'est bien
celui de l'abstention 25,4 pour cent
jamais les français ne s'était autant
abstenus de voter depuis 1969 à une
présidentielle
un chiffre auquel s'ajoutent les votes
blancs ou nuls 11,4 pour cent
là aussi un record entre l'abstention le
vote blanc ou nul dimanche
un tiers des français ont refusé de
choisir entre les deux candidats le
symbole d'un rejet celui des lecteurs
défiant qui ne pardonneront rien au
nouveau président à ce jour dans la
perspective des législatives
ils sont 61% a souhaité qu emmanuel
macron ne dispose pas d'une majorité
absolue de députés à l'assemblée
nationale
une petite idée du sacré défi qui attend
le nouveau président pour rassembler et
puis en bref premières manifestations
après l'élection d' emmanuel macron à
l'appel à du collectif front social
plusieurs centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées place de la halle
ligue à paris ce collectif avait été
appelé à battre les deux candidats
pendant l'entre-deux-tours
je vous propose d'écouter romain altmann
et c'est lui qui est à la tête de ce
collectif il est au micro de nelson
j'étais trop social en fait une
coordination de syndicats qui s'assoient
dessus de la cgt mais aussi collectifs
et d'associations co décidé de regrouper
pour faire face
la politique qui a été annoncé par le
nouveau président de la république
monsieur m'a conquis et lui hier soir
dans le but de dire comment c'est
monsieur mâcon poule et berné par
ordonnance
l'organisme est maintenant une riposte
au social à sa politique populiste donc
dès maintenant n'attendons pas les
ordonnances souvent il est coutume de
dire que des syndicalistes
un peu à la traîne et pas nous prend les
devants et on va tout de suite prendra
la direction de l'elysée où nous attend
saveria un rouge ex avait rien on sait
que françois hollande va et bien à
berlin pour ses adieux présidentielle en
gueule à merkel un calendrier allégé
pour l'actuel président d un calendrier
chargé pour le nouveau président
absolument delphine françois hollande a
quitté l'elysée il ya une heure
maintenant donc pour une visite éclair
une visite éclair à berlin avec un dîner
avec la chancelière allemande angela
merkel mais il sera de retour à l'elysée
dès ce soir à son agenda à demain des
entretiens avec les ministres jean marc
ayrault le premier ministre bernard
cazeneuve et ensuite dans l'après midi
michel sapin mercredi dernier conseil
des ministres pour françois hollande un
conseil des ministres qui a été avancé
car le chef de l'état se rendra ensuite
aux cérémonies de commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
il y retrouvera emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron qui ensuite se rendra dans
l'après midi mercredi après-midi en
bretagne pour assister aux obsèques de
la députée socialiste corinne erhel des
corinne erhel disparu brutalement
vendredi dernier puis en fin d'année
grand moment symbole est pour le chef de
l'état la passation de pouvoir elle aura
lieu dimanche encore peu de détails sur
cette cérémonie très protocolaire une
tradition républicaine qui laisse peu de
place aux surprises françois hollande
recevra d'abord emmanuel macron pour un
entretien en tête à tête puis direction
la salle des fêtes pour l'investiture
et ce sera ensuite laurent fabius le
président du conseil constitutionnel qui
proclamera les résultats emmanuel macron
raccompagnera ensuite françois hollande
sur le perron de l'élysée manuel macron
remontera ensuite les champs-elysées
pour se recueillir sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu sous l'arc de triomphe et
enfin il se rendre à la mairie de paris
comme le veut la tradition et puis enfin
delphine le nouveau chef de l'état se
rendra à berlin pour sa première visite
à l'étranger mais avant cela avant cette
visite officielle à la chancellerie
angela merkel le nouveau chef de l'état
pourrait aller saluer les troupes au
sahel c'est en tout cas ce que nous dit
son entourage
merci beaucoup à savais rien et on va
voir à présent comment l'élection d'
emmanuel macron été accueilli à
l'étranger avec ce reportage de mounir
souci un double sentiment de soulagement
et d'enthousiasmé a traversé les
principales capitales européennes à
l'annoncé des résultats
angela merkel a félicité le président
élu et se réjouit à l'idée de travailler
avec lui dans l'esprit d'une coopération
franco-allemande resserré emmanuel
macron porte l'espoir de millions de
français mais aussi de nombreuses
personnes en allemagne et dans toute
l'europe
il a mené une campagne pro européenne
courageuse il est pour l'ouverture sur
le monde
il est résolument pour une économie
sociale de marché
emmanuel macron a choisi l'aude à la
joie l'hymne européen pour faire son
entrée sur scène au louvre tout un
symbole
les responsables de lieux ont
unanimement salué son élection
jean claude juncker président de la
commission estime que par ce vote les
français ont fait le choix d'un avenir
européen en italie matteo renzi jusqu'à
présent une espérance se lève sur
l'europe et alexis tsipras ce
premier ministre grec voit dans cette
victoire une inspiration pour le
continent de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique un leader de la même
génération qu emmanuel macron félicite
le président élu justin trudeau se dit
impatient de travailler avec lui au
cours des prochaines années au-delà des
formules convenues emmanuel macron a
déjà échangé au téléphone avec la
première ministre britannique theresa
may au sujet du brésil et des futures
négociations aux états unis donald trump
est lui aussi pressé de démarrer ce
nouveau partenariat dans son message de
félicitations le président chinois à
jean ping espère faire progresser le
partenariat stratégique entre les deux
nations
vladimir poutine n'a réagi
officiellement que ce matin le président
russe
exhorte son futur homologue à surmonter
la méfiance mutuelle qui s'est installé
tout au long de la campagne avec des
déclarations d'hostilité mutuelle sur
fond de piratage informatique en
provenance de russie après la
présidentielle cap à présent sur les
législatives les français vont-ils
devenir une majorité emmanuel macron
pour mener à bien ces réformes quelle
opposition aussi on en parle avec mes
invités dans le premier débat
[Musique]
et mes invités ce soir j'ai plaisir
d'accueillir frédérique espagnac bonsoir
sénatrice socialiste des
pyrénées-atlantiques merci d'être avec
nous vous avez été le porte-parole de
benoît mans dans sa campagne pour la
primaire de la gauche également sur ce
plateau manuel bompard bonsoir je vous
étiez le directeur de campagne de jean
luc mélenchon vous être candidat de la
france insoumise haute garonne pour les
prochaines législatives merci d'être
avec nous
jean arthuis est également sur ce point
bonsoir député européen vous êtes
président de la commission des budgets
au parlement européen et vous soutenez
emmanuel macron j'accueille également
christian cambon bonsoir très bon
sénateur l'est républicain du val de
marne et puis gaëtan du sausset bonsoir
vous êtes membre du conseil stratégique
de la campagne de marine le pen
responsable des jeunes avec marine
première question pour vous aujourd'hui
puisqu'on voit richard ferrand qui
annonce la transformation du mouvement
en marche en la république en marche
avec les noms des candidats aux
législatives sur qui seront investis
dans les 577 circonscriptions qui seront
dévoilés jeudi
et on apprend aussi et bien que
finalement les candidats qui devait être
issu de la société civile pourront aussi
être élu est-ce que pour gagner les
législatives
emmanuel macron n'est pas finalement
obligé de transformer son mouvement est
tout la recomposition politique qui
l'avait appelé jusqu'à présent on a un
système de partis traditionnels son
élection est une espérance de
rassemblement des français très
largement la plus large possible
c'est aussi une espérance de rénovation
de la vie politique et donc il s'agit de
manifester du respect de l'ouverture de
la compréhension pour celles et ceux qui
voudront bien se présenter comme
candidat à l'élection législative sous
la bannière de la république en marche
avec la franche détermination
d'atteindre les dix objectifs du contrat
qu emmanuel macron en temps passé avec
les français finalement ça revient faire
de la politique comme on en faisait
jusqu'à présent avait calé la politique
ça ne vous a pas échappé mais ce qui est
novateur de la démarche des manuels
macron c'est que
mouvement s'est créée il ya tout juste
un an et qu'on a vu sur l'ensemble des
territoires français dans leur diversité
des jeunes des moins jeunes des hommes
des femmes participer à des collectifs
locaux s'approprier le débat politique
fait remonter des idées et le projets qu
emmanuel macron a soumis aux français en
se présentant comme candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
c'est celui qui a été conçu au plan
local on est partis du terrain
on est parti des acteurs locaux pour
faire remonter ses choix et ses
propositions et en faire une ambition
présidentielle pour la france pour faire
gagner la france a étendu ce auxerre on
voit qu'avec un score de plus de dix
millions de voix à marine le pen se
présente elle sait ce qu'elle a dit hier
soir comme la première force
d'opposition au projet du nouveau
président est ce que ce score vous
permettra d'avoir une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale mais bien
évidemment puisque en fait ce qui s'est
passé à travers cette élection
présidentielle c'est que le vieux
clivage poussiéreux gauche droite a
laissé place justement au nouveau
clivage entre d'un côté les mondialistes
avec emmanuel macron et le côté les
patriotes ça s'est confirmé évidemment
lors du soir du premier tour et ça s'est
renforcé avec les résultats de ce second
tour
il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui marine le pen
notre famille politique incarne la
meilleure opposition puisque la droite
notamment de monsieur fillon était
complètement discréditée au soir du
premier tour ou cinq minutes après les
résultats
ils sont allés apporter directement leur
soutien à emmanuel macron je ne parle
même pas du parti socialiste qui a bomb
a et dans un état au niveau de son
résultat du premier tour
donc voilà il y a la possibilité en
effet d'aller à marquer une véritable
opposition parce que les français en ont
besoin il ya un société aujourd'hui par
mois ya un projet qui est porté par
emmanuel macron un projet de division
deux sociétés de confrontation qui est
très important notamment avec ce projet
de loi travail puissance 1000 qui
passera par ordonnance dès l'été 2010
est et sur lequel il va falloir apporter
une masse de députés pour pouvoir s'y
opposer
christian cambon est ce que la droite
est en ordre de bataille pour cette
campagne pour les législatives on l'a
dit tiraillé entre opposition et
fascination pour emmanuel macron tuer la
droite est en ordre de bataille
il peut y avoir quelques individualités
qui effectivement manifeste avant même
que le président de la république
nouveau soit installé une appétence pour
entrer dans son gouvernement mais ce
sont des aventures personnelles
je pense qu'il faut respecter le
suffrage des électeurs au premier tour
nous avons soutenu un candidat qui c'est
qui s'est opposé à emmanuel macron donc
on va pas brusquement parce que
l'élection est terminée découvrir des
vertus cachées et nous retrouvons à la
faveur de l'élection législative une
juste répartition des forces en présence
il est vrai que nous avons appelé au
soir du premier tour à faire barrage à
marine le pen et nous avons assumé ce
choix
les résultats parlent d'eux-mêmes
singulièrement dans nos territoires dans
nos communes et nous l'avons fait en
responsabilité parce que ni le passé ni
les valeurs ni les projets ni la
personnalité de marine le pen ne nous
conviennent bien au contraire
à partir de là dire que parce qu'il ya
un nouveau président de la république à
qui nous souhaitons bonne chance car
nous sommes vous devez retrouver dans le
projet porté par emmanuel macron non
nous avons de véritables différences
doute il convient dre de débattre et les
législatives on est une bonne occasion
sur l'europe sur l'immigration sur la
lutte contre le chômage sur la sécurité
nous avons nous allons aider le
président macron et sa majorité à
éclaircir le débat on voit bien que
cette opposition qui sera et bien à
l'assemblée nationale tout le monde se
la disputent la france insoumise aussi
encore hier jean luc mélenchon des
commotions ma couette est minoritaire
dans le pays
oui par les skis est clair c'est que si
on tire le bilan du deuxième temps
l'élection présidentielle s'il y avait
effectivement une majorité pour chasser
madame le pen et je m'en réjouis
pour autant il n'y avait pas une
majorité pour ça se voit d'ailleurs les
français ont utilisé tous les moyens à
leur disposition pour dire non à madame
le pen et beaucoup de votes blancs une
abstention extrêmement forte
or aujourd'hui l'enjeu des élections
législatives maintenance avec de
construire une majorité pour pour un
projet de société et de ce point de vue
là moi je me positionne pas en
opposition et la france a soumises a pas
envie d'être la meilleure opposition en
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est pas un enjeu
d'opposition c'est à dire daniel van
gaal ont été aux élections législatives
autour de solutions qui sont les
solutions
vous seriez prêt à soutenir
bien sûr que non mais emmanuel macron
était donc aujourd'hui non aujourd'hui
l'enjeu est de déterminer la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale et nous on
considère que cette bataille dans le
débat démocratique bien sûr elle doit se
faire autour des différentes
propositions qui sont sur la table et
nous on ira à l'élection législative
avec l'objectif de construire une
majorité pour le partage des richesses
pour la planification écologique pour le
renouvellement démocratique dans ce pays
voilà et ça sera le débat maintenant de
ces élections qui permettra de
déterminer
enfin une majorité en cours encore une
fois je le redit hier nous avons eu un
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle qui règle aucune des
grandes questions auxquelles est
confronté le pays ce sera le l'enjeu des
élections et frédérique espagnac
justement je vous disais que richard
ferrand a expliqué la transformation du
mouvement en marchant la république en
marche vous proposer l'écouté
il va sans dire mais peut-être mieux en
le disant que nous refuserons tout
accord d'appareils ainsi que tout
mécanisme de double investiture
tous les candidats toutes les candidates
sollicitant l'étiquette de la majorité
présidentielle la république en marche
auront été investis par notre commission
nationale d'investiture il n'y a que
pour l'élection que la double
appartenance est proscrite puisque
compte tenu des règles électorales
les candidats doivent déclarer une
formation politique de rattachement pour
frédérique espagnac on voit bien que la
pression est sur le parti socialiste
avec les candidats qui devront choisir
entre l'étiquette ps est en marche je
crois pas du tout je crois que richard
ferrand vient de le dire je crois que
c'était important voilà chacun se
rassure une étiquette et on le sait bien
qu'on soit de droite comme de gauche
chaque candidat aux législatives un
devoir premier qui est allé s'inscrire
en préfecture et de cocher tout
simplement à quel parti il sera tout
simplement affiliés donc c'est ni plus
ni moins une clarification vous verrez
qu'il y aura des gens des républicains
qui auraient des gens du centre du modem
sans doute certains socialistes auxi
qu'ils y seront de franchir le cap
voilà et il y aura de la société civile
bon voila moi ce qui m'importe
aujourd'hui quand même c'est peut-être
se retrouver les uns et les autres
il ya deux choses y ait à la fois ces
images le sursaut d'hier soir de cette
population française en tout cas et de
ce dit
bon voilà le barrage a été fait et en
même temps moi j'ai le sentiment qu'on a
un devoir les uns et les autres
alors dd emmanuel macron chacun à notre
façon sans doute à réussir et infléchir
un certain nombre de choses mais si
jamais il ne reste rien compris aux
contributions du bar s'il ne réussit pas
vraisemblablement on aura donc la
responsabilité de le pen dans cinq ans -
c'est pas mon choix
ni aujourd'hui ça ne l'a été dans mon
vote dimanche ni demain par contre la
reine vampire l'aider à avoir une
majorité est fabriqué ça m'a coûté ce qu
elle donc tous les cas de figure où ça a
été dit manon part sur la législative
sera votre pour des convictions et après
on verra bien les majorités qu'ils
dégageront ou en marche aura la majorité
tout seul où elle ne l'aura pas et dans
tous les cas de figure on se retrouvera
les oreilles et les autres ont braqué ce
qui se passera mais voilà donc ça c'est
la première chose
la deuxième aussi voir les images à
l'international je crois que le sursaut
européen en tout cas un coup sûr si on
se retrouvera lui et moi sur ça je veux
dire moi je suis profondément européenne
et donc je crois qu'il est important en
tout cas face aux périls en tout cas
qu'on a aujourd'hui en europe de donner
un signal fort et tout simplement de
dire que à partir du moment où la france
est forte
c'est aussi l'europe est forte et donc
ça je crois que c'est aussi important à
souligner ce soit moi je crois que tout
à l'heure on faisait de d'emmanuel
macron le candidat de la mondialisation
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
la mondialisation et la rue et cette
élection devrait nous inciter les uns et
les autres est à sortir du déni de
réalité tout à fait la mondialisation ce
que je ne nous attend pas ce passage sur
internet le numérique et dans le mal
dans les mains de géant américain le gaf
a acronyme qui désigne google apple
facebook et amazon
croyez vous que la france à elle seule
en remettant ces barrières va pouvoir
réguler le numérique
comment se fait-il qu'on n'ait pas été
capable de créer des géants européens du
numérique seule l'europe et y parvenir
si vous voulez lutter contre les paradis
fiscaux
seule l'europe nous en donne les moyens
sur un certain nombre d'enjeux de défis
que nous lancer de menaces que nous
lance la mondialisation si nous voulons
reprendre en main notre destin il n'ya
que l'europe qui le permet nous voulons
une france forte dans une europe qui
nous protège je dis bien qu'ils nous
protègent contrôler les frontières
extérieures
quel est le pays qui à lui seul petit
parvenir
aucun il faut d'abord tarir les sources
de migration c'est à dire venir
développer l'afrique dont on sait bien
que des dizaines et des centaines de
millions d'habitants supplémentaires
revenir dans l'année qui vient à lui
seul l'europe peut le faire rétablir la
paix au moyen-orient
pour éviter ces migrations massives de
réfugiés qui fuient la guerre
seule l'europe et y contribuer oui bon
là on à du grand n'importe quoi déjà un
jeu vous entrez non pas si quand même là
vous raconter un peu je vous en avais
retrouve une carafe douze écoliers vous
le souhaitez le raz-de-marée sans merci
donc déjà premièrement j'ai dit
qu'emmanuel macron était le candidat du
mondialisme la mondialisation la
mondialisation est un phénomène est un
phénomène historique économique culturel
la morale le mondialisme est une
idéologie une idéologie qui consiste
justement à dépecer tout ce qui fait les
états nations et ça ce qui est justement
au coeur du projet dérivé de macron
maintenant sur la question de la place
de la france à travers le monde
moi j'ai pas cette vision faiblarde de
la france que vous partagez que vous
venez de témoigner aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau
moi je pense que la france est forte
elle est forte parce qu'elle peut
s'appuyer sur la francophonie
s'appuyer sur ces départements
d'outre-mer elle est forte parce qu'elle
a un espace maritime qui est puissant et
qui est très important dans le monde et
il a été trop souvent oubliée et voyez
vous je pense qu'au contraire plus on
laisse faire finalement l'europe à notre
place et plus et finalement si on ne
vous empêche maintenant et plus on nous
empêche finalement de protéger nos
intérêts le peuple français
aujourd'hui la place que nous nous
avions justement demandé et réclamé au
cours de cette élection présidentielle
s'était en effet d'avoir la possibilité
de retrouver le contrôle de nos
frontières nationales pas européenne
pour une simple et bonne raison c'est
que vous voyez notamment les frontières
il ya certes le problème migratoire
mais le problème aussi la concurrence
déloyale et les marchandises une
concurrence déloyale qui venait aussi au
sein de l'union européenne
non mais
on a les deux positions extrêmes on en a
déjà mangé là pendant les deux dernières
semaines à la fois une position
complètement euros béate cuir mais un
pas du tout encore rob et action
européenne telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
avec une position complètement
défaitiste consisterait à dire que
finalement on ne peut rien faire est la
france peut rien faire pour modifier les
rapports de force en europe
aujourd'hui la question posée monsieur
puisque vous voulez avoir une position
christique critique c est ce que par
exemple vous êtes d'accord pour remettre
en cause la directive des travailleurs
détachés
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour aller
vers des policiers des positions des
politique d'harmonisation sociale et
d'arts martiaux sont bien sûr mais alors
monsieur résidera il faut assumer une
position qui est une position de rupture
avec les traités européens actuels qui
empêche toute forme d'harmonisation
sociale et d'harmonisation fiscale
donc qu'est ce que va faire monsieur
macro est ce qu'il va aller discuter
avec partie on va renégocier les traités
reperdant je crois pas que je vais me
convertir mais si vous voulez vous
convertir à une position de
renégociation des traités européens qui
a été développée par jean luc mélenchon
commandes à la campagne vous êtes les
biens on n'a pas dit autre chose
on va déjà sur l'europe on voit bien
l'utilité des élections législatives
puisque on voit effectivement un certain
nombre de points de vue qui s'exprime
nous sommes tout à fait convaincu de la
nécessité de l'europe ceci étant je
pense qu'il faut aussi prendre
conscience des insuffisances de l'europe
l'europe n'a pas su maîtriser la crise
du chômage notamment en france du reste
à lire aussi elle n'a pas su maîtriser
la problématique de la sécurité celui
des réfugiés
une bonne gestion de l'immigration est
par contre elle a multiplié les
réglementations tatillonnes qui ont fait
de l'europe finalement très souvent un
repoussoir pour les gens qui n'en
perçoivent que les inconvénients
donc là aussi il y a non pas une
controverse mais il ya effectivement un
éclaircissement des explications à voir
avec emmanuel macron qui veut apporter
un nouveau souffle pour l'europe mais
pas dans les conditions de l'europe
actuelle je crois qu'on a bien
évidemment comme avant nous redonner la
parole
retrouvez tam traduit qui est justement
devant le qg des manuels macro camon
voix et bien le parti qui change de nom
le mouvement en marche qui change de nom
qui finalement se met en ordre de
bataille pour ces élections législatives
oui effectivement delphine henry à
l'instant richard ferrand les secrétaire
général non marche vient de faire une
conférence de presse lors de laquelle
elle a expliqué que emmanuel macron
avait bien démissionner de la présidence
du conseil d'administration aux
alentours de midi et qu'il était
remplacé à la présidence par intérim par
catherine barbaroux jusque-là délégué
national dans marche qui a est connu
notamment pour avoir été à la tête de la
dînée associations de microcrédit qui a
fait toute une partie de sa carrière
dans des cabinets ministériels de gauche
cela avant et d'un le congrès fondateur
du nouveau mouvement qui va s'appeler la
république en marche qui aura lieu le 15
juillet cela est bien entérine une
évolution pour mieux élargir l'assise du
mouvement ce sont là les mots de richard
ferrand richard ferrand qui a consacré
l'essentiel de sa conférence de presse à
la question fondamentale des
législatives il a précisé que la
république en marche investir et 577
candidats est qu'il n'y aurait pas de
double investiture sur cette élection on
imagine que c'est également une affaire
financière un puisqu'un candidat compte
tenu des règles électorales
aujourd'hui ne peut pas apporter par
exemple la moitié de son financement au
parti socialiste il souhaite rester
socialiste et l'autre partie à la
république en marche reste que richard
ferrand a également dit que la
république en marche n'obligeait
personne à déchirer sa carte
d'ailleurs sachez que dans le cadre de
l'alliance avec françois bayrou
il y aura également des candidats modem
qui auront un groupe modem indépendant
sachez qu on a également appris la date
à laquelle on en saura plus et on
connaîtra exactement la liste des
investitures ça sera pour ce jeudi à
midi merci beaucoup
tam pour toutes ces précisions jean
arthuis ce qu'il peut remporter ces
élections législatives tout seul
emmanuel macron tout seul puisque les
candidats viennent de différents
horizons et que
sans accord avec le ps en accord avec
les républicains pas d'accord avec des
appareils et on peut pas dire que m open
c'est un d'accord parties spécifiques
d'un appareil je ne suis pas en parler
pas membre du modem mais on veut
rassembler et je vois certains et qui
sont tentés de dire au fond on n'a pas
eu l'alternance à l'occasion de la
présidentielle
alors on aura l'alternance à l'occasion
des législatives
c'est à dire qu'on va aller vers une
cohabitation pour chacun sait que la
meilleure façon de mettre en vrille un
pays c'est d'aller en cohabitation donc
l'idéal naturellement c'est d'avoir une
majorité pour soutenir la politique etc
sur laquelle sur la base de laquelle
emmanuel macron a été élu à défaut c'est
d'avoir une coalition mais une
cohabitation c'est l'assurance de
difficultés majeures de perdre du temps
or il me semble qu'aujourd'hui la
situation est grave
le ton d'hier soir c'était le ton de la
satisfaction d'un élu qui est heureux du
résultat bien sûr mais c'était aussi la
gravité car le pays et est fractionné
déchiré on a entendu la colère de nombre
de français qui se sentent des classes
et qui ne voit pas très bien quel est
leur avenir
eh bien il s'agit de remettre chacun
dans une relation confiante et optimiste
ça n'est pas facile donc essayons de
faire taire certains de nos combats
quelques récents 46 ans et idéologique
la politique mais par un sport c'est pas
la gauche il ya il sait pas la droite
qui gagne c'est la france qu'il faut
faire gagner alors déjà les électeurs
ont rempli au rendu hier une réponse
contrastée puisque ça a été rappelé que
25 millions d'électeurs si j'additionne
les électeurs de marine le pen
les électeurs qui ne se sont pas
déplacés et ceux qui ont voté blanc une
25 millions n'étaient pas à la fête hier
soir donc je pense que c'est déjà un
message dont il faut tenir comment j'ai
du reste cru comprendre que
emmanuel macron avait entendu ce message
deuxièmement un sondage très intéressant
hier d'ipsos je crois a démontré que
plus de 60% des français ne souhaitent
pas je dis bien ne souhaite pas qu'il y
ait une majorité absolue au tour d'
emmanuel macron donc on voit bien qu'il
y a eu un vote bien souvent par défaut
puisque nous étions dans une situation
qui nécessitait cette position mais il
souhaite effectivement que ce ne soit
pas à nouveau comme ça a été trop
souvent le cas par le passé
un seul clan qui gagne qui l'emportent
et qui impose ses réformes
souvenons nous de 2002 avec jacques
chirac
ils l'emportent dans des conditions
encore plus important et il considère au
lendemain que l'affairé pliée que
maintenant on va dérouler sa propre
majorité moi personnellement je pense 1
qu'il n'est pas interdit à une formation
politique d' envisager de gagner les
élections c'est quand même la moindre
des choses c'est ce que dit le front de
gauche c'est ce que dit front national
est excusé si les républicains avec
françois baroin ont l'ambition de gagner
la majorité à l'assemblée nationale je
rappelle que c'est juste comme ça que ça
se passe dans tous les pays
démocratiques côté une élection
législative on veut la gagner
si il n'ya la majorité n'est pas aussi
clair s'il n'y a pas une majorité
absolue pour les macs ont effectivement
dans ce cas là il y aura peut-être une
coalition et à ce moment là on discutera
et on verra sur quels points mais a
priori nous partons évidemment très
franchement pour gagner des élections
législatives ce qui est la base du
combat en politique alors manuel campa
non mais je pense effectivement que il
faut pas vouloir confisquer le débat au
fond j'ai pas question de compter
jusqu'à elles et les français ils ont eu
un deuxième tour qui leur a pas permis
d'avoir le débat sur les projets de
société franchement on a vu ce deuxième
tour qui était quand même assez
lamentable ou franchement izy fa les
échasses et madame le pen je pense que
dans les ici on est réjouit de l'avoir
fait en l'occurrence on a vu dans cette
2e tour l'élection le rôle du front
national dans notre démocratie c'est à
dire vous le mettez là et puis en fait
n'importe quel candidat vous avez en
face en fait et en capacité de remporter
le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle ce qui permettra de
renseigner chacun qui pensent que le
front national est une bonne opposition
ce n'est rien du tout puisqu'il suffit
d'être en face de lui pour être élu bref
il faut pas confisquer ce débat n'a pas
eu le droit d'avoir ce débat au deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle entre
les différents projets de société donc
moi je l'assumé je le revends d'y
exceller
jce latif qui doit permettre de l'avoir
oui effectivement mais sur a rappelé que
c'est pas uniquement la volonté
différentes organisations politiques
c'est la volonté des français qui pour
dans les résultats d'hier ont montré
qu'ils n'étaient pas sur un vote
d'adhésion et qui dans les sondages qui
sont faits dans les enquêtes d'opinion
disent clairement que pour l'instant ils
souhaitent une cohabitation donc
maintenant la question qui est posée
c'est le débat qu'on a initié
aujourd'hui et qui va avoir lieu pendant
les prochaines semaines c'est une
cohabitation autour de quel projet
monsieur porte un projet pour jour
donnant la parole après 3 bien que le
parti socialiste est tiraillé entre bien
le soutien voire l'opposition à emmanuel
macron un peu laissé sur la touche aussi
par jean luc mélenchon alors on voit
tout de suite à les explications 226
requins jean luc mélenchon offensif se
pose dès hier soir en opposant numéro un
à emmanuel macron une nouvelle majorité
parlementaire est possible autour de
nous notre résistance peut gagner la
bataille et je vais m'y employer avec
vous de toute mon énergie
le leader de la france insoumise veut
transformer l'essai dans les soixante
sept circonscriptions où il est arrivé
premier mais son manque de volonté à
conclure des alliances à gauche y
compris avec les communistes pourraient
lui coûter des sièges une fois de plus
benoît hamon lui tend la main pour celui
qui incarne la gauche du ps
pas question pour le parti de se fondre
dans en marche il faut défendre une
opposition frontale au nouveau président
si la gauche se rassemble
si elles se rassemblent dans sa
diversité
elle peut être majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale soyez en certains al'inverse
pour la gauche de gouvernement ségolène
royal en tête
il faut participer à la majorité seule
façon d'éviter une débandade comme en
1993 où le parti a été réduit à une
cinquantaine d emmanuel macron a réussi
à casser les oppositions traditionnel
droite gauche et je dirais une certaine
forme de violence dans la politique
maintenant le temps est venu de
travailler ensemble demain lors d'une
réunion à huis clos
le ps doit débattre de sa ligne pour les
légistes
yves et les échanges promettent d'être
vifs tant le parti est fracturée entre
ceux qui veulent travailler avec
emmanuel macron et les autres frédérique
espagnac et on a du mal à comprendre
quelle va être la stratégie et
parlementaires du parti socialiste vis à
vis et bien d' emmanuel macron est-ce
que vous pouvez nous éclairer on voit
d'un côté effectivement ceux qui vont
maintenir leur candidature dans la
circonscription puis d'autres comme par
exemple olivier faure qui dit on peut
trouver une majorité d'idées ne faut pas
forcément faire de blocage tactiques des
choses sont assez simples demandes un
bureau national donc c'est pas moi qui
veux vous donner la ligne qui ressortira
vous avez vous voyez bien les divisions
et encore moi j'ai plutôt envie
d'appeler les socialistes à la
responsabilité on a aujourd'hui au sort
avec une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale
on voit bien ta situation va être très
difficile et je crois que l'essentiel
aujourd'hui c'est de permettre à chacun
des candidats qui sous l'étiquette
socialiste soit en capacité tout
simplement d'être réélu donc les
divisions elles sont importantes dans
tous les cas de figure c'est une fois je
pense que les élus socialistes le seront
que potentiellement on décidera après
s'il ya une coalition s'il y en a pas
qui décidera de de faire une opposition
à gauche ou pas à gauche pour l'instant
je constate en effet que jean luc
mélenchon ne nous tend pas la main mais
dans tous les cas de figure je crois que
vous savez bien le parti socialiste a
été quand même assez tiraillé pendant la
fois la primaire moi j'étais au départ
se soutenait le président de la
république donc je me suis rangé au des
deux candidats qui étaient benoît hamon
et dans tous les cas de figure
aujourd'hui nous avons un débat en
interne
bon voilà donc tout ce que j'espère en
tout cas c'est que les restes des
socialistes soient responsables pour pas
mais voyez vous retrouver dans ce n'est
ma force progressiste au tour d'emmanuel
macron vaut à titre personnel d'un kayak
écoutez la question se pose pas
aujourd'hui mais dans tous les cas de
figure moi je ne serai pas de
l'opposition systématique ça ne peut pas
être le cas ce serait ça fait forcément
à un moment donné il y aura forcément
des textes que je voterai parce que je
serais d'accord nous allons nous sommes
retrouvés sur un certain nombre de
propositions et monsieur arthuis il ya
des choses sur lesquelles je ne suis pas
d'accord
bon voilà donc je pense que oui on peut
partir en vacances en espagne fait prête
peut-être à franchir le pas qu'est ce
que vous pouvez lui
encore que cette importance et nos
convictions et nos idées dont il ya des
choses sur lesquelles je serais d'accord
avec lui on a dit sur l'europe sur
d'autres sujets sur d'autres je les suis
moins bon la suppression de l'imposition
sur les grandes fortunes je le suis
moins voilà c'est pas suppressions
s'élèvent on retire de l'assiette de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune et
tous les éléments de capital qui
contribuent au développement des
entreprises tout le capital productif de
grâce si nous voulons recréer l'emploi
car c'est bien ça le sujet
comment lutter contre le chômage de
masse donc redonner les mains
d'actionnaires de s'enrichir rejet de
mâcon
redonnons jeu les marges de liberté la
formation chantiers prioritaires la
formation professionnelle
l'apprentissage est également très
important et pour le chômage des jeunes
naturellement les quelques pays
européens qui pratiquent l'apprentissage
de longue date et par tradition
l'allemagne les pays bas l'autriche
n'ont pas de chômage des jeunes donc
sommes nous capables de prendre les
meilleures pratiques de nos partenaires
pour les appliquer chez nous et lutter
ainsi efficacement et redonner de
l'espérance et de l'optimisme à ces
jeunes il est temps du soc et envoie
coeur en marche modifie son nom se
transforme en c'est que marine le pen
aussi un appel à une transformation du
front national c'est la condition
nécessaire justement pour avancer vers
ces législatives une transformation du
front national on voit aussi de ligne
qui s'affrontent au sein de votre parti
non je sais pas où vous voyez de ligne
mais j'ai entendu l'ensemble des cadres
du front national et les des militants
du front national hier tout le monde est
absolument vouloir faire une petit drone
à monterrey non mais marion maréchal-le
pen j'ai entendu en direct également à
la télévision hier soir et on va pas
refaire le scénario quand même ça il ya
deux ans s'il vous plaît donc juste une
petite remarque et après je reviens sur
la question du mouvement politique une
petite remarque sur tout ce qui a été
dit avant et en particulier par le parti
socialiste et le parti des républicains
moi j'espère juste que vous serez
parfaitement honnête transparent et
sincère avec les électeurs lors de ces
élections législatives parce que là j'ai
l'impression qu'on va aller un peu en
disant bon bah moi finalement je suis
avec le parti socialiste massue avec les
républicains pour finalement tout se
retrouver après de même
minutes avec suffisamment sincère avec
les électeurs et gland le coulant
paquebot avait été insolent dans une
douzaine est au top en voilà ah bon
c'était logique population 2e manche
sont rongés de jany respect total des
électeurs
l'argent on mènera une enquête là-dessus
et on pourra dire ce qu'il en est alors
maintenant sur la question du mouvement
il se trouve qu'en fait entre le premier
tour et le second tour nous avons
quasiment accueilli près de plus de
trois millions d'électeurs nouveau des
électeurs qui lors du premier tour
n'avait pas nécessairement choisi marine
le pen ou nicolas dupont aignan mais
peut-être françois fillon d'un côté ou
jean luc mélenchon de l'autre donc il
est évident qu'ils vont revenir
justement personne personne n'est
propriétaire de ses vannes à chaque
électeur et vivre en conscience de voter
pour qui il souhaitait pour le projet
qui pensent le plus à même de pouvoir
défendre ses intérêts donc maintenant il
faut que nous nous soyons en mesure
évidemment d'évoluer de nous transformer
pour accueillir justement aussi c'est
assez patriotes sincères qui ne sont pas
tous aujourd'hui au front national
et pour ce faire et bien nous évidemment
nous concerterons en interne nous
concerterons avec nos adhérents pour
pouvoir faire évoluer la plateforme
christian cambon les sionistes qui ont
pu voter marine le pen au second tour
ils reviendront à vers le parti des
républicains pour les législatives
écoutez d'abord ils n'ont pas été si
nombreux que ça si je regarde si je
regarde les chiffres
je crois que notre position qui
consistait à faire barrage à marine le
pen était très clair je les dis ça a été
dit sur tous les tons et j'ai trouvé
assez succulent le fait pendant des
années le front national nous a accablé
de connivence avec le
le collègue socialiste après depuis
quinze jours on nous faisait la danse
des sept voiles pour montrer que nous
les patriotes on devait rejoindre marine
le pen
en fait ce ne sont pas du tout oui je
vous remercie le problème c'est que nous
avons un programme nous avons des
valeurs peuvent être plus compatible
avec certains - avec d'autres mais je
pense que encore une fois la nécessité
du débat des législatives est très
important on le voit en quand quelques
minutes on voit que chacun a des
solutions à apporter
et le peuple français doit trancher
comme dans toute démocratie et c'est ce
à quoi nous allons nous atteler bien
c'est un risque fort de division non
c'est partir des républicains dont je
parle les explications de sa section on
en reparle de rejoindre l'équipe d'
emmanuel macron bruno le maire se
laisserait bien tenter et l' annonce des
résultats hier soir il a proposé ses
services au nouveau président j'essaie
depuis des années à droite je suis monde
des républicains j'ai donné de l'énergie
j'ai travaillé comme mini zoo
agriculture comme responsable des
questions européennes
j'ai toute ma place à droite je peux
travailler d'une majorité le
gouvernement
après c'est mon parti qui fera le choix
qu'il voudra bien faire un basculement
peu apprécié par françois baroin le chef
de file dlr pour les législatives l'a
répété hier soir il sera intraitable pas
d'investiture pour ceux qui franchissent
le pas il quitte la famille
il quitta valide alors cif actuellement
il faut faire une liste on fera une
liste mais il ya aucun problème n'a
aucune ambiguïté le bureau politique a
tranché c'est clair c'est net et sans
bavure une ligne claire mais à droite
plusieurs semblent hésiter parmi eux
christian estrosi mais aussi les
juppéiste comme jean pierre raffarin
fabienne keller on attend des preuves
d'amour j'allais dire des actes mais
cela correspond aussi à un besoin de la
france si on veut réformer
il faut rassembler toutes celles et tous
ceux qui sont prêts à faire des efforts
pour valérie pécresse
les élus aient l'air doivent mettre
leurs ambitions personnelles de côté il
y aura des aventures individuelles mais
moi je le dis nous serons unis avec le
centre pour cette bataille des
législatives parce que ce qui se dessine
c'est les réformes de demain c'est la
conduite de la france de demain
pour le moment la droite part unie
pour sauver ses sièges à l'assemblée et
essayer d'avoir une majorité aux
législatives du gouvernement
oui c'est les ralliements individuels on
a toujours connu ça souvenez vous en
2007 le président sarkozy avait cru bon
ton d'ouvrir le gouvernement à quelques
personnalités
on a vu ce qu'il en était et ça n'a pas
du reste mobilisé les partis de gauche
pour brusquement se mettre à soutenir
nicolas sarkozy pendant son quinquennat
donc je pense effectivement que les
aventures individuelles
elle mérite d'être jugé à l'aune de ce
qu'elles sont non ça n'est pas que deux
aventures d'un des vignobles sont
envoyés les jupes et ce aussi bien
quitté jeudi la déclaration la vente
j'ai eu ce matin là dans le soir du
premier ministre on parle par exemple du
merdier
mais j'ai lu la déclaration d'alain
juppé lui-même qui a dit que l'union de
la droite et du centre étaient
véritablement le socle du combat des
législatives et qu'il allait lui-même
prendre part à au succès de ces de cette
alliance
donc je pense qu'il faut que chacun
reste soi même et que les électeurs
donnent leur avis sur le sujet
non mais je pense qu'il faut pas perdre
de vue quelque chose qui a traversé en
profondeur l'élection présidentielle
qu'est ce que nous on a appelé la vague
des gages east mais en tout cas qui
était ce ce profond de sa profonde cette
profonde aspiration à renouvellement
politique il ya un paysage politique est
mort au sort du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle les deux
partis traditionnels de la vème
république ont été éliminés et là on
sent bien que ce mélange aussi du reste
bien sûr mais jean-luc mélenchon pour
l'instant il est dans l'élection
présentés n'étaient pas au second tour
alors que vous vous y avez été à toutes
les élections précédentes depuis le
début de la vème république
donc il ya quelque chose qui a qui s'est
profondément transformé dans les
rapports de force dans la société il ya
une profonde aspiration à un
renouvellement politique et là bon c'est
un peu sauve qui peut et on a
l'impression que les vieilles forces
politiques s'accroche un peu pour
essayer de se maintenir dans le jeu et y
compris de ce point de vue là les
dernières déclarations de monsieur
ferrand qu'on a vu tout à l'heure sont
un peu inquiétantes c'est à dire que
c'est un peu déjà un premier reniement
c'est à dire ça devait être un grand
renouvellement et puis on se rend compte
que finalement les 50% de société civile
peuvent être des élus finalement on se
rend compte que la double appartenance
en réalité est possible parce qu'on
cache derrière des arguments juridiques
finalement le fait que ça peut être une
forme de recyclage des élus de l'aele
voilà je crois que cette aspiration faut
faut l'entendre il faut y rester
compatible avec cette aspiration
renouvellement
démocratique qui s'est exprimée dans ce
pays donc je pense que ça va être un des
enjeux de la bataille c'est que le
renouveau il est du côté de la
république en marche puisque au moins 50
% des candidats seront des candidats des
femmes et des hommes qui jusque là n'ont
pas siégé au parlement
le renouveau est là et le rassemblement
est là aussi des femmes et des hommes
venant de la gauche venant de la droite
et du centre
en dehors des discussions d'appareils la
règle est simple vous êtes candidat
parce que vous acceptez ce rassemblement
dans sa diversité
c'est pas le ralliement au lendemain des
élections c'est des hommes et des femmes
en train d'aboutir justement sa position
c'est ce que manuel valls va avoir votre
échec majorité présidentielle par
exemple c'est une vraie question pour
les français je pense qu'ils se sont
limités à la case en marche
ça veut dire que il est dans le
mouvement dans le parti politique dont
un congrès qui se tiendra au mois de
juillet après jura formellement la
crèche mais c'est votre droit mais
convenez que c'est un peu contradictoire
avec l'idée de faire du renouvellement
non je pars dont le renouvellement c'est
au moins 50% des candidates et des
candidats sacré candidats ayant pas
nécessairement vocation aller vers des
circonscriptions difficile pour se faire
élire à fribourg il faut 12 5% des
inscrits pour être au second tout ça est
compliqué et on va être quatre ou cinq
sur la ligne de départ
le maniaque dans tous les cas de figure
je crois que la responsabilité de chacun
d'entre nous en tout cas de nos partis
politiques respectifs sera en effet de
montrer aux électeurs qu'on a entendu le
message
donc le renouvellement se fera peut-être
en marche nous les sociale et sera les
présenter de demain il évoque vous allez
voir des surprises puisque nous on a
hâte et déjà dès le début un certain
nombre de choses sur la féminisation 50%
sur le pourcentage de nouveau c'est à
dire la société civile des gens qui
n'ont jamais été élus et qu'ils seront
candidats
voilà donc nous en tout cas on a pris
nos responsabilités très vite
et de ce point de vue là je crois qu'il
fallait entendez les électeurs et les
électrices je crois que je ne vous
respecte c'est peut-être faire attention
au pouvoir de nuisance que peut avoir le
parti socialiste dans certaines
circonscriptions où il pourrait faire
chuter à l'est quand
en mars il y aura des désistements
possible des accords dans certaines
circonscriptions coûté pour l'instant on
en est à désigner nos candidats donc ça
c'est la première étape voir quand même
que dans certaines circonscriptions nous
demande face au front national on aura
tous des responsabilités que nous on les
a toujours prise au parti socialiste
rappelle que ce que nous avons fait déjà
pendant les élections régionales
donc on verra les uns et les autres je
rappelle quand même et il faut se dire
que eux
en effet sur la ligne de départ est
d'ailleurs beaucoup de monde il va y
avoir la france a soumises vais voir les
verts eelv à vivre le parti socialiste
va y avoir en marche il va y avoir les
républiques peut-être y avoir et le
front national donc là aussi ça veut
dire mais qu'est ce que c'est vraiment
laid pas sinon ca attendu le message des
français hier écoutez les prix autant de
candidatures fra bat jusqu'à présent en
tout cas le message il a eu lieu hier
excusez moi donc certains partis ont
décidé de je sais pas si certaine en
tout cas rassemblements peuvent se
fermer
en tout cas si on y va éclater les uns
et les autres de part et d'autre je
pense qu'on seront peut avoir des
grosses surprises
moi en tout cas je souhaite que le front
national soit le plus bas possible à
l'assemblée nationale même si un certain
nombre de français
voilà et c'est pour ça que je dis qu'il
y a urgence au delà de notre petit nos
positionnements respectifs
il ya urgence à entendre ses électeurs
qui ont à 11 sports à 20 11 millions
quasiment 10 millions voter front
national à ses électeurs qui se sont
abstenus à ses électeurs
voilà ça aujourd'hui si les uns et les
autres on n'est pas en capacité de
répondre vite et de faire en sorte en
tout cas que emmanuel macron qui
indéniablement aujourd'hui le président
de la république apporte des solutions
rapidement et en tout cas c'est le futur
gouvernement qui soit quoi une coalition
ou cohabitation apporte des réponses
rapides aux français dans leur quotidien
parce que c'est une stat ondes
aujourd'hui les français enfin vous
savez chez moi aujourd'hui pyrénées
atlantiques un département passe et
rural je veux dire une femme
d'agriculteur à la retraite c'est 300
euros où est la dignité pour vivre et
300 euros après une vie de travail
appareils pour un agriculteur à un
agriculteur 800 euros voilà ça c'est pas
une visite mais c'est pour ça que je le
dis mais enfin il faut entendre aussi ce
qui s'est passé donc c'est en ça qu'il
faut que les uns et les autres on a pas
d'erreur l'ancienne coalition ya aussi
un risque pour emmanuel macron de voir
son message diluer son identité
non mais l'objectif c'est d'avoir une
majorité pense aux intérêts politiques
c'est ce que la cinquième
un public a généré au lendemain des
élections présidentielles
le débat a eu lieu à l'occasion
d'élections présidentielles et sur le
code du travail par exemple on ne sera
pas dans la situation de la loi elle
comme ris parce que ça fait partie du
projet cas portu et emmanuel macron il y
a naturellement nécessité j'ai lu sur
son projet encore une fois hier il a été
qualifié sur son projet au premier tour
sa victoire est incontestable on nous
annonçait depuis des mois depuis deux
ans que marine le pen serait en tête au
premier tour
semak roncq est arrivé en tête donc
c'est lui qui a été qualifié pour le
second tour
les partis traditionnels avait des
candidats qui n'ont pas été qualifiés
comme si la d'humilité justement mais ne
reproduisons pas les uns et les autres
ce que j'avais fait en sorte voyons
aujourd'hui le veau du deuxième tour
d'emmanuel maquereau au sein d'un
ensemble de français et ce n'est pas sur
le projet des manuels m'accueille et le
sillage du lit mais ce n'est pas un
blanc-seing rage aussi manuellement oui
je crois que c'est dur on touche là la
grande incompréhension de l'élection
d'hier
beaucoup de commentateurs ont dit
emmanuel macron a fait barrage au front
national et on peut aussi inverser la
proposition le barrage au front national
a peut-être fait monsieur macron et
comme il l'a dit hier moi je le prends
au bout et dit qu'il souhaitait
rassembler le pays mais qu'il le monde
et si il ya une majorité qui est plus
composites à l'assemblée nationale mais
il fera avec parce qu'il est président
de la république il est à démocrate et
il en tiendra compte
et c'est donc à nous exposer nos idées
de nouba pour qu'elles soient les
meilleurs possibles et qu'elle
convaincre les français non mais le
schéma il assez clair il ya songé que
vous mettez sur la table sont les sujets
de l'élection législative les choses
sont claires si les français veulent
effectivement détruire le code du
travail il faut qu'ils votent pour vous
mais j'aimerais s'ils y pensent au
contraire qu'il faut résister et aux
côtés du député contredire sur la loi
elle comme rire étendre les droits des
travailleurs faut qu'ils votent pour
dossier les jean-paul chôma revoir des
accords de libre échange le taffetas le
sais tape ce que vous parlez de lait des
agriculteurs on a eu ce trailer ils ont
fait à voter pour les candidats en
marche ils y pensent au contraire qu'il
faut s'opposer à ce projet de
libre-échange et son cas voter pour les
candidats de la france a soumis c'est ça
le débat qu'on va avoir le vrai rival
sur la
s'ils permettent d'avoir ce débat entre
ces grandes orientations puisqu'on n'a
pas pu la voir à l'occasion du deuxième
tour des élections présidentielles même
enjeu pour vous oui ou non mais je
comprends bien que monsieur arthuis que
les équipes des manuels macron sont un
peu inquiète à l'idée ces élections
législatives
comment ils vont faire pour réussir à
avoir une majorité au sein de
l'assemblée nationale puisque évidemment
le projet d' emmanuel macron n'est pas
du tout majoritaire dans l'opinion
française que ce soit sur le détricotage
du code du travail que ce soit sur le
laxisme face à la menace du terrorisme
islamiste sur l'accueil des migrants et
cetera il est minoritaire de la
population française donc pour ce faire
s'il va falloir faire c'est évidemment
permettre justement aux patriotes de
rentrer en masse pour permettre ainsi
aux pattes de rentrer au mas se défendre
lui même au sein de l'assemblée
nationale c'est ça qui est essentielle
et en fait ce dont nous avons
cruellement besoin aujourd'hui c'est un
renouvellement
certes mais un renouvellement des idées
d'abord pas seulement des visages etc ou
même de la société civile parce que
c'est un terme qu'on utilise à toutes
les sauces société civile sauf que quand
on regarde la presse quatre dents il
n'ya pas d'ouvriers ya pas de boulanger
ya pas d bauer il n'y a pas de routiers
etc
ces quatre sites mais même quand c'est à
dire celui ci on regarde on regarde la
société civile voilà c'est à dire que
avant les politiciens faisait science
pour lena est ensuite allé directement
politique aujourd'hui conscience pour
léna cabinet de conseil pdg cac 40
et après ils se mettent en politique le
profil de vos candidats nous nous aurons
justement l'ensemble de la diversité de
la population française des étudiants
comme c'est mon cas également des noms
mais je serai candidat dans la 2e
circonscription de l'ouest tout à fait
mais pour être crédible il faut quand
même
avoir une cohérence aussi dans ses
positions vous savez parce que là vous
venez d'essayer de prendre le temps
d'art de la lutte pour le droit dans ce
style mais depuis des années je crois
maintenant quand madame le pen quand il
y avait des manifestations contre la loi
elle conneries insulter les manifestants
et les consulter vous disiez c'est un
moment il faudrait pas regarder on va se
calmer tous et on va dire aux gens qui
nous écoutent vous allez aller à parler
des grilles casseurs allant des
manifestants contre la loi y compris on
parle et coûteront et puis nous dirons
juste alerter les français si on me
laisse aller au nord qu'au bout de ma
phrase en ml j'ai raconté alerte ou quoi
ce que je raconte n'importe quoi les
gens vérifieront je voulais juste
alerter les français sur le fait que
cette force politique le front national
qui va essayer de vous expliquer qu'elle
défend vous enterrer les droits des
travailleurs
la fin de la loi elle comme riz etc ah
oui les positions tout à fait
contradictoires ces dernières années et
que je les appelle de la part de clients
qui partagent exactement la même équipe
que mathieu coquerel qu'à voter pour
monsieur mâcon c'est à dire la loi
travail puissance mille maux face à ses
intérêts
il aimerait bien vous calmez vous tout
va bien devrait bien que l'on considère
celles et ceux qui ont voté pour
emmanuel macron comme des patriotes eux
aussi c'est pas parce que on a la
sagesse à un moment donné de constater
qu'au plan national on n'a plus vraiment
les moyens d'assumer la plénitude d'une
souveraineté
c'est en la partageant qu'on garde cette
souveraineté et n'est pas question de
transiger sur les valeurs qui
caractérisent la france c'est cela notre
démarche et donc les patriotes je
prétends qui sont aussi du côté de ceux
qui pensent que nous pouvons garder
notre souveraineté et assurer la prise
en main de notre destin
en donnant à l'europe les capacités
politiques dont elle a été privée
jusqu'à maintenant nous sommes les
premiers à critiquer le fonctionnement
de l'europe ne voulons pas laisser cette
critique au front national
mais ce que nous voulons nous c'est
changer justement le fonctionnement de
l'europe en commençant par renforcer la
zone euro
et donner un véritable pilotage pilotage
dans lequel le président de la
république française doit s'impliquer
directement comme françois hollande dont
l'investissement pour conclure avec vous
l'espagnol espère pardon un petit mot de
conclusion peut-être justement sur cette
majorité sur la stratégie ni partielle
du parti socialiste ont lésé on en saura
plus demain s'est targué on en saura
plus demain on verra aussi demain les
candidats aux législatives auront été
fortement renouvelée vous verrez demain
féminisé 50% renouvellement bien plus au
delà de 50 % de candidats nouveau donc
ça aussi il faut le mettre au crédit de
jean christophe cambadélis qui a réagi
assez vite
en l'occurrence aux résultats qui se
sont passées et puis j'ai envie de dire
aussi peut-être répondre quand même sur
leurs proies que si l'europe a été quand
même on est tous critiqué qui on aspire
tous à la changer ou face il a été
stabilisé telle qu'elle a été si la
grèce a été potentiellement sauver c'est
aussi grâce à françois hollande donc
excusez moi ça va coûter
mais chacun aujourd'hui on avait un
homme qui n'est présent république avec
une certaine émotion nouveau janvier
puissent quand même de lui rendre
hommage et le liban doit nous rappeler
ce qu'a été la raison d'être de notre
séjour merci beaucoup à jean arthuis
merci gaëtan des sauces et merci
christian cambon merci manuel mon parent
il est bientôt 19 heures toujours en
direct sur public sénat dition spéciale
au lendemain de l'élection d' emmanuel
macron avec cette première cérémonie
officielle pour lui après sa victoire à
la présidentielle
dt ce matin aux côtés de françois
hollande pour les commémorations du 8
mai la passation de pouvoir entre les
deux hommes aura lieu dimanche prochain
à l'elysée à 39 ans elle devient donc le
plus jeune président de la république
avec 66,1 % des voix devant marine le
pen qui obtient 33 9% des suffrages
nous reviendrons sur cette ascension
éclair mais aussi sur les défis qui
l'attendent alors que 16 millions
d'électeurs ne se sont pas exprimés dans
les urnes à la bataille des législatives
a débuté on vient d'en parler emmanuel
macron veut construire une majorité de
changement mais l'étroitesse de son
socle électoral risque de lui compliquer
la tâche
le front national plr la france
insoumise se disputent le titre de
première force d'opposition analyse dans
un instant je rappelle que vous pouvez
réagir à cette émission via twitter avec
le hashtag présidentielle à 360 pour
m'accompagner ce soir sa verrière ogec
en direct de l'elysée et un traduits
devant le qg et d'emmanuel macron le
multiplex s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
on va tout de suite retrouvé ta mme tran
huy devant le qg des manuels macron au
thème je le disais la stratégie se mette
en place pour les législatives avec un
nouveau nom et le nom des candidats qui
seront investis qui seront connus dès
jeudi
et oui effectivement on a pris tout ça à
travers une conférence de presse tout à
l'heure de richard ferrand secrétaire
général du mouvement en marche qui nous
a expliqué que maintenant que emmanuel
macron devenait président de tous les
français bien il avait à midi
démissionner de la présidence du conseil
d'administration dans marche il est
remplacé par intérim par catherine
barbaroux jusque-là délégué national du
mouvement une discret soutien de la
gauche depuis longtemps un catherine
barbaroux qui a fait une partie de sa
carrière dans des cabinets ministériels
socialiste qui a fait également une
incursion dans le privé avant de
terminer sa carrière à la dia première
association de microcrédit en france
dont elle sera président par intérim
richard ferrand reste lui secrétaire
général du mouvement avant un grand
congrès de refondation qui aura lieu le
15 juillet pour refonder le mouvement
qui s'appellera désormais la république
en marche cela pour évoluer et pour
mieux élargir l'assise du mouvement et
vous le disiez et bien richard ferrand
également bien sûr parler des
législatives en marche investira eh bien
il faut le dire 577 candidats il n'y
aura pas de double investiture sur cette
élection
on écoute à ce propos richard ferrand il
va sans dire mais peut-être mieux en le
disant que nous refuserons tout accord
d'appareils ainsi que tout mécanisme de
double investiture
tous les candidats toutes les candidates
sollicitant l'étiquette de la majorité
présidentielle la république en marche
auront été investis par notre commission
nationale d'investiture il n'y a que
pour l'élection que la double
appartenance est proscrite puisque
compte tenu des règles électorales
les candidats doivent déclarer une
formation politique de rattachement oui
vous l'avez compris un cette question du
rattachement administratif à la
république en marche c'est aussi une
affaire financière puisque compte tenu
des règles électorales actuelles
un candidat ne peut pas apporter par
exemple la moitié de son financement à
un mouvement comme le parti socialiste
et l'autre partie de son mouvement à la
république en marche il faut donc qu'il
apporte la totalité de son financement à
un seul mouvement
reste que pour entendre et bien la
république en marche ne demande pas à
ses candidats de déchirer leur carte
électorale et respecte la pluralité des
sensibilités politiques alors richard
ferrand nous a dit également tout à
l'heure et bien que il connaissait déjà
la liste des 577 candidats qui sont
investis mais il ya encore quelques
vérifications à faire et elle sera
connue de façon publique jeudi à midi
merci beaucoup
tam pour toutes vos explications alors
emmanuel macron a été lu en guise avec
66 20 % des voix il devance clairement
marine le pen la candidate fn qui
obtient 33 points 9 mai le taux élevé
d'abstention liste et de blanc et deux
nuls fragile et sa victoire ce matin cet
emprunt de gravité consciente des
responsabilités qui découlent de son
élection qu'elle s'est rendue aux
commémorations du 8 mai 45
aux côtés de françois hollande tout un
symbole quand un calme
c'est la première image des deux
présidents ensemble à l'occasion des
commémorations du 8-mai emmanuel macron
place c'est pas dans ceux de françois
hollande est lui hier soir le nouveau
président de la république ne sera
investi que dimanche mais déjà l'actuel
chef de l'état a invité son successeur à
cette cérémonie officielle le président
hollande qui à plusieurs reprises guide
ostensiblement son successeur pour lui
indiquer la marche à suivre et afficher
leur complicité
françois hollande qui aujourd'hui ne
cachait pas son émotion et beaucoup
d'émotion d'être sur ces lieux et puis
je vais beaucoup d'émotion aussi disons
le très franchement très sincèrement de
donner à emmanuel macron la marche à
suivre
une première image ensemble symbolique
avant la passation de pouvoir est une
introduction au protocole
emmanuel macron qui a aujourd'hui
rencontré pour la première fois en tant
que président de la république les
principaux responsables des forces
armées
une cérémonie où étaient présents de
nombreux politiques dont nicolas sarkozy
de son côté françois hollande vit
désormais ces derniers jours en tant que
président de la république en exercice
[Musique]
deux présidents qui seront à nouveau
réunis dans les jardins du sénat
mercredi pour les cérémonies commémorant
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
[Musique]
et on va tout de suite retrouvé sa
verrière rejet qui nous attend en direct
de l'elysée savait rien quand un calmant
le disait eh bien françois hollande vit
ses derniers instants comme président de
la république absolument delphine
françois hollande s'est rendu ce soir à
bell à berlin pour une visite éclair un
dîner avec la chancelière allemande
angela merkel mais il sera de retour à
paris à l'elysée dans la soirée
demain dernier entretien individuel avec
tout d'abord jean marc ayrault suivie
d'un déjeuner avec le premier ministre
bernard cazeneuve
puis dans l'après midi michel sapin le
ministre de l'économie mercredi matin
dernier conseil des ministres à conseil
des ministres qui a été avancé car
françois hollande se rendra ensuite aux
cérémonies de commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé les
retrouvera emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron qui se rendra ensuite mercredi
après midi donc en bretagne pour
assister aux obsèques de la députée
socialiste corinne erhel comme nrl
disparu brutalement vendredi dernier
dernier moment symbolique ensuite pour
le chef de l'état pour françois hollande
la passation de pouvoir elle aura lieu
dimanche peut-être à 10 heures encore
peu de détails sur cette cérémonie très
protocolaire une tradition républicaine
qui laisse peu de place aux surprises
françois hollande ne recevra tout
d'abord emmanuel macron pour un
entretien en tête à tête puis direction
la salle des fêtes pour l'investiture
et ce sera laurent fabius le président
du conseil constitutionnel qui
proclamera les résultats avant que
emmanuel macron raccompagnant françois
hollande sur le perron de l'élysée
manuel macro qui remontera ensuite les
champs elysées pour se recueillir sur la
tombe du soldat inconnu sous l'arc de
triomphe et enfin il se rendra en fin de
journée à la mairie de paris c'est
également une tradition sachez enfin que
le nouveau chef de l'état se rendra bien
à berlin pour sa première visite à
l'étranger c'est ce que confirme son
entourage
mais il pourrait d'abord un
faire une visite solennelle également
allés saluer les troupes françaises au
sahel
merci beaucoup savaient rien alors à 39
ans emmanuel macron devient le plus
jeune président de la république encore
inconnu du grand public il y à peu il a
réussi son pari
retour sur cette ascension éclair avec
marie brémaud il paraît sur ces images
presque intimidé un visage quasi
juvénile alors qu'emmanuel matheron se
tient aux côtés de son père en politique
françois hollande qui lui a mis le pied
à l'étrier
d'abord en tant que secrétaire général
adjoint de l'elysée en 2012 puis au
ministère de l'économie en 2014 pour
succéder à arnaud montebourg
en tout cas je me permettrai un conseil
pour toi la plus belle arme en politique
c'est la sincérité sache l'utiliser et
tu verras les autres te suivront on ne
sait si emmanuel macron a suivi ce
conseil mais il a su convaincre certains
socialistes et même au delà quand il
quitte bercy en août 2016
une décision guidée par l'ambition et
qui marque une ascension fulgurante
j'ai mis du temps j'ai réfléchi j'ai
consulté j'ai associé
beaucoup de gens et j'ai décidé qu'on
allait créer un mouvement politique un
mouvement politique à sciences po dea
pena banque rothschild le cv des manuels
macro est bien rempli en cette rentrée
l'ambitieux vise désormais l'elysée il
se veut sans étiquette
inclassable et rassembleur l'homme
libéré s'est affranchi
nous ne travaillons pas à des
recompositions deux parties nous
travaillons pour le pays et la
refondation politique à laquelle nous
travaillons n'a pas besoin d'être
suspendu au mouvement des uns ou des
autres changements d'humeur
à 39 ans emmanuel macron est le plus
jeune président de la vème république
une jeunesse un atout pour incarner le
renouveau politique qu'il défend
affaire à suivre en tout cas pour lui
l'histoire est en marche
[Musique]
et on continue d'analyser cette victoire
d' emmanuel macron avec mes invités sur
ce plateau jarre le gall bonsoir vous
êtes analyste politique merci d'être
avec nous également avec nos pierre
lefébure bonsoir vous êtes chercheur au
laboratoire communication et politique
maître de conférences en sciences
politiques à l'université paris xiii
j'accueille également vincent jarousseau
bonsoir vous êtes co auteur du livre
l'illusion nationale deux enquêtes dans
les villes fn paru aux éditions el les
arènes à merci d'être avec nous et de
jean daniel lévy bonsoir directeur du
département politique et opinion chez
harris interactive le premières qui sont
pour vous gérard le gall puisqu'on vient
de voir cette trajectoire cette
ascension spectaculaire qui finalement
bouscule les codes traditionnels de la
politique emmanuel macron d'accord elle
réussit son pari de ce point de vue ah
oui remarquablement mais met rapidement
à tous égards jusqu'à maintenant en tout
cas je me suis amusé à regarder les
itinéraires des présidents alors de
gaulle 46 58 65
ça fait du temps pompidou 62 9 7 ans
françois mitterrand 1965 1981 26 ans
enfin je peux continuer ainsi nicolas
sarkozy si on commet 180 eu d'élu faut
que 20 ans françois hollande comme en
cent quatre-vingts son circuit en
corrèze puis 15 ans et lui un an deux
ans enfin en disons si 16 mars là donc
c'est effectivement une fulgurance sans
précédent depuis la révolution française
enfin n'était bon à part peut-être enfin
bon mais on n'est pas dans la république
là on est enfin temps encore un peu mais
pas totalement
bref donc c'est une réussite
extraordinaire mais ça parle beaucoup de
lui et ça parle aussi peut-être encore
plus de la société française dont on
disait qu'elle était à ce point
monarchique qu'il fallait des gens donc
sûrs au moins 60 ans et c'est donc sa
part au sida société française et ça
nous oblige désormais en parler
différemment c'est bien le fait bloc et
quel regard vous parler sur cette
fulgurante ascension qu'on veut dire les
français à travers cette élection mais
ce qui est caractéristique c'est que
d'un point de vue chronologique
effectivement on n'est pas du tout
habitués à cette temporalité ni par
ailleurs
relativement jeune âge de l'impétrant
qui devient président en un temps aussi
record en revanche c'est les mécanismes
qui peuvent peut-être nous alerter il y
en a sans doute à ausculter sur la
société française
il y en a aussi sur j'allais dire
l'économie générale du système politique
français parce que la façon dont
emmanuel macron a réussi cette
trajectoire assez son personnage il a
réussi à se poser lui-même en s'opposant
ou la reconfigurer jusqu'à un nouvel
écosystème non plus gauche droite nous
dit-on alors que ces formations
politiques existent encore qu'elles ont
mené des campagnes de primaires dont au
moins celle de la droite était identifié
comme un phénomène absolument massif de
participation quasiment 10% du corps
électoral et dans celle de la gauche
beaucoup plus tardive était en retrait
par rapport à celle de 2011 mais donc il
va substituer à ce clivage gauche-droite
une forme de appel au renouvellement
tout en disant maintenant c'est les
progressistes contre les antieuropéens
même pas les conservateurs mais en gros
pour faire simple extrême droite contre
le progressiste un petit peu
indifférenciée gauche droite donc c'est
le mécanisme générique de cette
trajectoire ascensionnelle qui est aussi
très impressionnant et qui interroge sur
ce que notre écosystème politique va
vraiment devenir
est-ce que ça va vraiment être ça le
clivage est ce que c'est vraiment comme
ça que ça va se réorganiser ou pas et
pourtant un ami et l'évier bien malgré
le score élevé ans a été rappelé 66,1 %
il a quand même bénéficié d'un la
puissance du rejet de la candidate fn
pour vous absolument mais là comme été
qualifiée pour le deuxième tour ce n'est
pas forcément écrit ou assurer dès le
départ pour revenir sur ce que vous avez
indiquée ce qui est intéressant c'est
que depuis de nombreuses années quand
nous on pose la question aux français
demandant quel est le président de la
réplique idéal que nous disent ils c'est
plutôt quelqu'un de jeune quelqu'un qui
a et un passage dans le privé et un
passage en politique quelqu'un qui a une
forme d'honnêteté qu il capable de
sortir des carcans des formations
politiques et de rêve de ramener à lui
des électeurs ou des idées qui viennent
de la droite et de la gauche qui a une
profonde honnêteté dans le sens probité
mais également honnêteté d'un point de
vue financier
et enfin qui est à l'écouté quand vous
prenez ces six cases on peut voir que
ces six cases sont cochés au départ par
emmanuel à cons ça voulait pas forcément
dire qu'ils allaient nécessairement
gagné mais ça voulait dire que au départ
il y avait un regard
autour de sa personnalité qui
construisait un rapport singulier avec
ce qu'on peut appeler l'opinion ça s'est
manifesté et ça s'est manifesté et dans
les raisons du vote dans le cas du
premier tour et dans les raisons d'un
mobilisation dans le cas du deuxième
tour on voit bien que nous sommes face à
des électeurs qui disent on l'apprécient
le responsable politique
on pense qu'il a cette capacité de
pouvoir renouveler un peu la vie
politique d'une manière générale pour
différentes raisons et vous avez raison
de l'indiquer ça n'a pas pu se produire
est l'émergence de personnalités plus
difficiles par le passé et dans ce
contexte là emmanuel macron a su être la
bonne personne au bon moment mais encore
une fois en cohérence avec une
aspiration des français qui est une
aspiration à ses anciennes macron marine
le pen elle est ce qu'elle est
réellement bénéficié d'un vote
d'adhésion justement par rapport à
emmanuel macron sur les 10 millions de
personnes qui se sont prononcés en sa
faveur
ce qu'il faut souligner dans le résultat
de maille le pen c'est que difficilement
les réalités annoncé beaucoup plus haute
il comprit pour ce second tour puisque
on l'a annoncé autour d'eux car au delà
des parents pour ça il avait 40 %
pendant quasiment tout tout l'entre-deux
tours sauf depuis le débat du mercredi
mais mais néanmoins le score qu'elle a
réalisées même s'il est en deçà de ce
qui était annoncé
reste un score historique par rapport à
l'histoire de ce parti si on le compare
par exemple au score de jean marie le
pen en 2002 effectivement par rapport à
ce qu'on a pu voir avancer ça c'est un
vote d'adhésion
mais c'est un vote qui traduit
effectivement en france une fracture
profonde une des fractures puisque moi
je considère qu'il ya un certain nombre
de fractures dans ce pays et pour
revenir à la question précédente autour
d' emmanuel macron je ne crois pas que
ce soit le le président idéal que les
français aient des îles est ce moi je
vois plutôt un candidat par un président
par défaut et je me pose y compris la
question de s'agacer retourner en
premier tour il ya peut-être eu vent je
parle je parle de second tour et je
moi je me pose la question par rapport à
toutes les enquêtes que l'on a pu mener
sur le terrain pendant un certain nombre
d'années sur cette france dit
périphériques sur ces territoires où le
vote front national a fortement
progressé
on peut s'interroger pour savoir si
emmanuel macron restera peut-être
justement ce dernier
c'est vrai que c'est le défi il en a
conscience il l'a dit hier il doit de
parler à tous les français et notamment
aux électeurs lui national très souvent
les hommes politiques sont plus
intelligents que le discours contient
sur eux pour les avoir fréquentés
certain nombre d'entre eux assez haut
niveau je pense qu'ils ont une analyse
très aiguë alors ce qui parfois est en
rupture avec le discours qu'ils tiennent
mais ils connaissent les choses il les
mesures il les apprécie
avec plus ou moins de bonheur il croit
que avec emmanuel macron on a quelqu'un
qui a la tête froide qui résonne
rationnellement et qui est habité par
une énergie mais moi je m'inscris ac en
faux sur cette notion d'ailleurs
sondagière qui est apparue il ya
quelques sur la notion adhésion ou par
défaut moi je ne sais pas très bien ce
que ça veut dire parce que c'est un
mixte et je suggérerais notamment à
notre sens d'heure à notre ami sondeurs
de disques faire une position en quatre
c'est à dire on peut être à la fois dans
l'adhésion et dans et par opposition et
si c'est pas incompatible or là c'est
très manichéen et on raisonne beaucoup
trop d'ailleurs dans la politologie en
général en termes binaires grosse droite
le haut le bas avec ses terrains les
deux france les trucs six états si je
puis me permettre
c'est quand même la question sociale qui
est ressorti de cette élection à notre
grande surprise tout le monde pariait
sur le fait que cette élection
présidentielle tournerait autour des
questions identitaires et des questions
de sécurité et d'immigration
et finalement quand on voit les
thématiques qui sont ressortis
re découvre finalement la fameuse
fracture sociale qui avait été sorti par
la nouvelle tonnes en 1990 gauche entre
autres et puis qui était ressorti aussi
en 2005
et voilà je pense que c'est aussi le
défi auquel est confronté et emmanuel
macron sachant que nous sommes à la
mi-temps du processus 1 la deuxième mi
temps
elle est au moment des élections
législatives on va venir justement jean
daniel lévy puisque red sont définis on
le disait à emmanuel macron de
s'adresser à tous les français à la fois
les électeurs frontistes mais aussi ceux
qui ne sont pas rendus aux urnes en
rappel ce chiffre de l'abstention
historique aux alentours des 26 % avec
un vote aussi un taux record pour les
votes blancs et nuls et seulement alors
décide pas être manichéen viennent
parfois aussi il est pas le risque est
donc absolument certain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui dans le vote à l'égard d'
emmanuel macron il ya un vote autour de
sa personnalité et pas autour du projet
politique qu'il a portées et que quand
on interroge les français sur ce qu'ils
imaginent de ce que pourrait faire
emmanuel macron demain en terme
d'alliance en termes de position
politiques voire même en termes de
politiques publiques ou voire de
réformes qu'il pourra entreprendre
il ya une difficulté aujourd'hui la part
des français à pouvoir entrevoir cela et
que autant à l'égard des autres
candidats lorsqu'on l'interrogé les
électeurs y avait une vision qui est une
vision claire parfois réductrice autour
d'un ou deux enjeux qui apparaissait
comme étant relativement clair mais là
il ya une interrogation qui se porte à
l'égard des manuels m'apprendre
probablement que son premier défi sera
de dire voilà le type de france que je
vous propose à l'horizon de 2022 ou
après et voilà dans ce contexte les
réformes que je propose pour pouvoir y
parvenir et que ça permettra de passer
au dessus justement des clivages qui
sont des clivages partisans parce que
quand on regarde globalement
l'aspiration général à la société
française est l'idéal de la société
française on est sur des regards des
regards et i trans partisan et
transgénérationnel et voire même
traverser les différentes catégories
sociales
ce qui d'ailleurs par ailleurs est
intéressant c'est qu'on a retrouvé vous
l'avez indiqué non seulement des livres
pension sociale dans le cadre de ce
débat mais également un regard que l'on
voyait apparaître en 2005 en tout cas
qu'elle ait émergé dans le cas du débat
sur le traité constitutionnel européen
avec une inspiration entre d'un côté ce
qui pouvait dire g
besoin de protection et dans ce contexte
de là je suis critique à l'égard de la
construction européenne et ceux qui
d'une manière globale considéré qu' à
travers leurs conditions de vie ou leur
statut ils pouvaient ne pas avoir besoin
d'autant de protection que le reste de
la cité française
mais par rapport à ce qu'on est en train
de dire est quand même un hiatus assez
profond parce que si on revient sur les
conditions de franchissement du premier
tour pour accéder au second tour nous
disait ton depuis déjà assez longtemps
celui ou celle qui parviendrait au
second tour avec quasiment élection
gagnée face à marine le pen pour un
certain nombre de raisons telles que le
front républicain plus ou moins j'allais
dire bien configurer ou pas et là en
fait ce qui se joue et c'est dès le
premier tour
et sur ce score de 24% en lui-même ni
totalement faible initalement très fort
par rapport à des élections précédentes
on a une composition de cet électorat
qui effectivement beaucoup
d'incertitudes c'est que autant sur des
traits d'image il peut y avoir une
appréhension plutôt positive du manuel
macro lui ceci même parfois à
l'intelligence alors que tous les
analyses de son discours nous disent qui
a rien de transcendant dans son
expression bon donc il ya des traits
d'image qui fonctionne très bien
en revanche ça suscite pas l'adhésion ni
sur des propositions politiques claires
il sur un horizon lui a souvent reproché
ni de qualifier son programme il de
clarifier son horizon est donc
finalement quand on observe à travers
différentes enquêtes nous on a fait
plutôt du qualitatif dans mon
laboratoire mais aussi quelques
indicateurs quantitatifs et les
institutions d'âge divers et variés haut
calibre et aux alentours de 40 à 50% de
son électorat deux premiers tours ce qui
fonctionnait déjà à autre chose que de
prime abord l'adhésion prédire anticiper
un vote de barrage au front national
dès le premier tour plutôt que
simplement au second donc on a un
président qui est non pas mal élu parce
que deux tiers des voix à la fin on a
l'impression que c'est magistral mais
qui dans les différentes enquêtes
d'opinion n'est pas crédité d'un fort
soutien à l'idée de vouloir lui attribue
une majorité aux législatives ça c'est
quand même confondant d'habitude la
logique de la vème république c'est
d'avoir cet effet d'entraînement
là on n'en disposent pas donc on est
dans un relatif loup non pas sur les
qualités de l'individu non pas sur sa
très bonnes relations avec les médias
par exemple n'y avait que différentes
formes de des expertises diverses dans
la société
mais quand on son rapport avec la
population à ses différents segments aux
différentes questions sociales etc
on est vraiment dans un absence j'allais
dire de certitude totale donc emmanuel
macron pour le féliciter de sa victoire
c'est un communiqué
la maison-blanche charles garnier mais
moi je pense que il faut qu'on
réapprenne à penser le phénomène nouveau
c'est à dire moi ce que j'entends la ce
camp même des catégories danalyse assez
convenue et qui donc ne s'applique pas à
lui
oui mais et donc il faut s'interroger
sur le fait que la nouveauté va nous
obliger à avoir des critères d'analysé
différents noms laurent pouvoir rester
sur ce créneau de la nouveauté on voit
qu'il a commencé à transformer son
mouvement en marchant parti et la
république en marche on voit qui va être
rattrapé au système pardon la pratique
du pouvoir le rattrape
oui enfin le rattrape on dit ça depuis
longtemps qu'il faut rester dans des
créneaux habituels et c'est lui et c'est
un fonceur on va dire les choses de
manière très simple et il a une
stratégie manifestement il a un
implicite programmatique fac était quand
même évident qu'on peut situer
idéologiquement relativement facilement
et je crois que c'est le 18 juin la date
même tout à fait le hasard le 18 juin
silsilah une majorité soit relative soit
absolue que l'on pourra effectivement
voir une dynamique ultérieure
mais je crois que là il ya quand même
quelque chose qui nous oblige à penser
différemment la notion d'adhésion alors
le par défaut il ya un effet de système
quand même naturellement un effet de
vote c'est à dire que un premier tour on
a 1 24% qui est pas une jauge historique
très élevé on a un deuxième tour 25 % et
+ abstentions un niveau d venant non
une abstention politique mais on est
face à un phénomène ou n'a pas été
construit pas en un nom mais si je peux
me permettre de parler de nouveauté mais
c'est l'emballage qui est nouveau à
l'intérieur
non mais voilà enfin sur le fond il faut
quand même se positionner par rapport à
ce que les gens ressentent et voix je
veux dire en parcourant ces villes
dirigées par le front national pendant
deux ans en osier en auditionnant en
discutant longuement avec ses électeurs
du front national
qu'est ce qu'on entend on entend des
gens qui ont un besoin de reconnaissance
for marine le pen a parlé des invisibles
par les invisibles et en l'occurrence sa
candidature un carnet d'une certaine
manière cette forme de reconnaissance
qu'il recherchait jeu ils font pas ça la
position mais en tout cas elle était
vécu comme celle qui reconnaissait d'une
certaine manière ces populations entre
guillemets déclassé parce qu'il n'ya pas
que des déclassés parmi les électeurs du
front national
mais moi par rapport à emmanuel macron
la perception que j'en ai assez c'est un
beau produit marketing
effectivement mais derrière la question
qui se pose c'est la question de la
fonction présidentielle
je reviens ce que je disais tout à
l'heure est ce que il est souhaitable
pour réseaux vous résoudre les problèmes
qui sont devant nous aujourd'hui aussi
bien institutionnels politiques sociaux
et économiques
est ce qu'il faut s'en remettre à une
seule personne est ce que on n'aurait
pas un peu besoin de diversité dans la
représentation poétique est ce que
quelque part les français ne seraient
pas tentés d'aller au bout du processus
en ayant une sorte d' une forme de
majorité relative forme de coalition qui
regrouperait des personnes
et des personnalités politiques très
différentes c'est peut-être le
changement sionnel c'est aussi les
institutions elles mêmes et les
pratiques politiques et les cultures
politiques lui façonnent ce n'est qu'un
début
peut-être que ça va avorter je n'en sais
rien moi je ne suis pas je pas militant
de deux ans marche j'essaye d'analyser
je pense qu'on a tort d'analyser avec
des catégories classiques
un phénomène qui est d'une émergence un
phénomène au sens étymologique du terme
ce qui émerge
et quand on voit une telle fulgurances
pardonnez moi mais on peut pas utiliser
des catégories un peu 10 ans et de
l'empaquetage de ces deux là comme quoi
bon ça fait un an qu'on dise à lui
d'ailleurs entreprises publiques est
important qu'on attend c'est la
nomination de son premier ministre à
jean daniel lévy est ce que vous avez
sondés justement les électeurs pour
savoir le profil qu'il souhaitait être
il faut quelqu'un de centre-droit centre
gauche c'est toute la question sera
déterminant pour les législatives
alors on a sondé et on n'a aucune
réponse claire voile aussi franchement
ça arrive et que par le passé y ait de
la part des électeurs
une tendance qui en général façon ne se
traduisait pas politiquement en 2002 les
électeurs de droit constitutionnel
donnait une à deux niveaux différents
c'est qu'un aujourd'hui en termes de
premier en termes de personnalité
il n'y a pas une personnalité qui
s'impose en tant que tels que ce soit
françois bayrou que ce soit jean louis
borloo autre qui donne le sentiment que
c'est lui le candidat naturel et pas
plus que en 2012 il y avait jean marc
ayrault qui aux yeux des électeurs
apparaissez comme étant absolument le
candidat légitime en pas en complément
se pose la question de la majorité dans
le cadre de la semaine nationale
il peut y avoir des différences entre
eux le souhait est ce qui se produira au
final du fait du mode de scrutin ne vous
l'avait indiqué vous avez raison on a
aujourd'hui moins d'un électeur sur deux
qui déclare qu'il souhaite que emmanuel
macron est une majorité dans le cadre du
prochain de la prochaine législature se
suffit encore besoin de ça suffit pas
forcément parce qu'en fait mais
ça suffit - moins d'un sur deux moins
d'un sur deux est donc dans ce contexte
là ce qu'on peut voir également c'est
qu'on a notamment des électeurs
républicains qui considèrent je veux
qu'ils ne sont pas retrouvés die à la
candidature de françois fillon et que
dans le cadre des prochaines élections
initiative
ils ont l'intention de revenir notamment
dans leurs familles politiques
traditionnelles
parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu exprimer le
message qu'il soit exprimée depuis le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2012 c'est à dire
prendre leur revanche sur la précédente
élection présidentielle on voit bien
justement bien la fibre il est rattrapé
un par toute cette tradition des partis
politiques même s'il a pu obtenir le
soutien des mélanges chemises des
fillonistes aller aux législatives
chacun réflexe il est rattrapé et c'est
normal comme le serait d'ailleurs tout
vainqueur de la présidentielle dans un
milieu politique raidir qui est
aujourd'hui chahuté depuis maintenant
bien des années et certains disent que
c'est tout le quinquennat qui a été
chahutée pour différentes raisons
on a besoin d'une majorité aux élections
législatives tout simplement et on est
un système politique présidentialiser
notamment en termes de logiques
politiques notamment depuis que les
législatives depuis 2002 ont été passés
juste derrière la présidentielle mais
fondamentalement on est un régime
parlementaire en france donc ça nous
apparaît pas toujours aussi clairement
mais il ya un enjeu manifestement
suffisamment important avec les chattes
yves pour qui manuel macron soit en
train de configurer la machine
électorale où la machine politique
certes un petit peu innovante à certains
égards mais qui reste une machine
politique en changeant le nom en
organisant les l'un des investitures
pour les législatives et en voulant ne
laisser aucun interstices aucun espace à
des alliances mais en prescrivant à ses
électeurs et à d'autres de le suivre
avec 577 candidature partout et bien
merci à pierre lefébure merci vincent
geloso merci gérard le gall merci à vous
jean daniel lévy merci à vous d'avoir
suivi cette édition à 22 heures la suite
dun
is du décryptage de cette présidentielle
avec sonia mabrouk et ses invités bonne
soirée à tous et à demain dès 17 heures
[Musique]
il